je ne sais pas paul emile victor si les
catastrophes naturelles telles que
celles dont nous parlons à présent sont
exactement votre spécialité
mais quand même à cette question d'ordre
général peut-on les les sinon les
prévoir du mois les prévenir
non ça n'est évidemment pas ma
spécialité je suis un polaire
essentiellement un polaires ont 20 sont
des questions qui m'intéresse
je ne crois pas effectivement qu'on ne
peut aujourd'hui faire quoi que ce soit
sauf ce que vous disiez madame prévoir
davantage une protection des zones mais
là encore ça paye pas et c'est pour ça
que on ne fait pas ça paye
moralement psychologiquement ça devrait
être possible financièrement mais ya pas
de doute que dans la plupart des cas on
ne le fait pas on ne le fait pas aussi
parce qu'on espère que ça n'arrivera pas
chez nous ça n'arrivera pas ailleurs
même des gens qui le sont directement
liés affectivement cela dit chacun sait
que comme pour les tremblements de terre
par exemple tazieff vous en parlerai
bien mieux bien sûr comme pour les
troubles en terre il ya une carte que
l'on peut être il ya des zones à ce
sujet comme les temps le notaire ou
comme ce que ce dont nous allons parler
tout à l'heure je pense à savoir les
incendies il ya fort longtemps qu'on
aurait pu faire un effort beaucoup plus
grand et on le fait dans d'autres pays
pour éviter que les incendies ne
prennent les proportions absolument
catastrophique de l'été dernier vous ne
publiez un livre là dont nous en parler
tout de suite d'ailleurs ce sera une
bonne chose de faite et ça défile
jusqu'au cou nous y sommes jusqu'au cou
je suppose
oui c'est à dire que et comment s'en
sortir est en réalité le titre les trois
points vous voyez après jusqu'au cours à
lui être avant jusqu'au cou ce qui veut
dire tout simplement nous sommes dans la
merde jusqu'au concert et c'est vrai que
de la merde depuis longtemps à propos de
la question wang est décomposé d'un
instinct vous dites qu'il est l'homme a
une très grande une trop grande
prétention à son infaillibilité
lorsqu'il est scientifique ou
techniciens lorsque les scientifiques
techniciens peut-être mais aussi
simplement lorsqu'il est
ni l'un ni l'autre l'homme est tellement
sûr de lui même et l'a appris au cours
des métaux du dernier siècle avec les
progrès de la technique il a appris que
il est beaucoup plus fort que tout le
reste et qu'il a été beaucoup plus il
s'est développé beaucoup plus
techniquement parlant qu'au cours de
deux millénaires précédent est il a par
conséquent le sentiment que ne peut rien
lui arriver ou s'il lui arrive quelque
chose vraiment c'est pas de sa faute
or mon impression c'est que en dehors
des problèmes de solutions techniques
la plupart des choses qui nous arrive
aujourd'hui évidemment pas le cyclone
mais bien d'autres choses encore et la
faute de l'homme de ses excès et des
individus des des personnalités la
grande erreur je pense que l'homme fait
et de penser que ce qu'il fait lui n'a
pas d'importance qu'il n'y peut rien à
l'aquoiboniste dont je parle
alors que ce sont les autres qui devrait
faire quelque chose d'abord et les
gouvernements les états en particulier
or ça commence par lui
[Musique]